do you think it's okay to say things  like men are trash  i feel like yes and i have a reason  because okay why  statistically like men have been trashed  for so long  for so long i'm talking beginning of  time  for so long men have been doing like  really bad stuff like saying men in  trash like mental trash is okay but i do  feel like  you know like you're gonna be like in a  jokey way you've gotta be like okay like  this is not like i don't really mean  like you're trash like you're like okay  so what if what if guys said women are  [ __ ]  like in a joking way  i mean  like personally but they they kid you  know what i mean i think is that it's  kind of in the same plane like it's in  the same domain like the same kind of  you really do you think people would  have the same reaction so if i said men  are trash and he says women are [ __ ]  like do you think it'd be the same like  you know fair enough